we're gonna have to look at the
Appropriations process and limit funds
going to some of these agencies
particularly the ones who are engaged in
the most egregious Behavior so the doj
and the FBI yeah and yeah the doj and
the FBI they want to defund federal
police they say we are for Law and Order
and against defunding the police but all
of a sudden Donald Trump has to comply
with the law and the legal orders as
they love to obsess with of law
enforcement and prosecutors and so on
and so forth and all of a sudden they
say get rid of the entire department
defund the FBI defund the doj
these are the very same people who while
saying we support the police and you're
bad for wanting to defund the police
we're on the side of the rioters rather
than the police when it came to the
January 6th riotus insurrection